One of the most important insights that evolution has into the nature of
patients is that patients are bundles of tradeoffs.
They are not machines with replacement parts that can easily be switched out
anytime one intervenes to change.
One thing there will be consequences in other things in the patient because
their traits are connected through tradeoffs
tradeoffs required two connections.
One is a connection between the traits.
The other is a connection between the traits and fitness.
Now each of these connections can be either positive or negative and the trade
off only exists when a change in one trait that increases fitness is associated
with a change in another trait.
The decreases fitness.
Yeah.
One Way to conceive of trade offs is his energy allocation,
so that is a physiological way of looking at trade offs within a single
individual.
The idea of being that there was a limited amount of energy which is coming in
that's represented here by the diameter of the pipe are and then a fraction of
it see is being allocated to one function.
In this case fee come to d and the rest of it,
one minus C is being allocated to another function in this case survival.
That's called the y allocation model and it was developed by Nord and the young.
It has some surprising outcomes.
Yeah.
Basically what is going on here is that if the variation is mostly in how much
energy is acquired,
then this would be little energy acquired here.
This would be a lot of energy acquired here,
lower line,
little energy,
the upper line,
a lot of energy.
Then the variation and acquisition produces a positive relationship between
reproduction and survival.
If however,
the variation is mostly an allocation,
then there's not too much variation in acquisition and most of the variation
then is in this region here leading to a negative association between
reproduction and survival.
This analysis makes clear why it is that rich people have big houses and Nice
cars.
That's a variation and acquisition.
If everybody were acquiring about the same amount of money overall than what we
would see is that people can either have big houses or big cars,
but not both.
This is also a reason why we think that tradeoffs are expressed under food.
Stress in organisms are under other kinds of stress,
which tends to shrink the variation in acquisition,
leaving the variation in allocation exposed is the source of the trade off.
Yeah.
Now,
tradeoffs can occur with an individuals are among members of a family or a
group.
So in kestrels clutch size trades off with age and maturity and clutch size of
offspring.
Yeah.
And her Sophala Malana gastar old females lay eggs that have higher juvenile
mortality than do eggs laid by young females.
So something in the mother is trading off with something in the offspring.
The same thing in some sense happens in red deer where the effect on the
mortality of the mother
is greater if she has a daughter than if she has a son for the sun moves away
sooner.
Whereas the daughter stays closer to the mother and then competes for food.
So the gender of the offspring determines the reproductive tradeoff.
To some extent in red deer in general,
tradeoffs can occur within any set of interacting individuals whose interactions
affect fitness
tradeoffs can be measured by phenotypic correlation or by genetic correlations.
Phenotypic correlations can exist for many reasons.
Not all of them are genetic.
They can be for reasons of environmental variation.
Phenotypic plasticity contributes to them only connections among traits that
have a genetic basis.
We'll produce tradeoffs that have evolutionary consequences.
Therefore,
the most convincing way to measure a genetic tradeoff is as a correlated
response to artificial selection.
The idea here is that one selects on one trait and then sees how the other trait
responds and if an improvement in one trait leads to a decreased performance
through the other trait,
then you've demonstrated a trade off.
Here is an example of measuring tradeoffs is correlated responses to artificial
selection.
It was done in fruit flies.
Now this is a summary of a tremendous amount of information.
It's 14 studies done in five labs involving about a hundred man years of work in
the boxes.
Here on the left you can see some major life history traits such as
developmental time,
body size,
longevity,
early fecundity in late fee committee and in the boxes on the right and you can
see some underlying physiological traits such as desiccation,
resistance,
ethanol resistance,
you'll protein messenger,
RNA meeting speed with young and things like that.
What I would like you to do is follow the arrows and what you can see here is
that if you select for increased development time than the consequence,
the trade at the other end of the Arrow is a larger fly.
If you select for larger flies,
then the result of the other end of the Arrow is longer development time and
those are indicated by these plus signs.
However,
if you select for early fecundity is to increase number of eggs laid early in
life.
That reduces lifespan.
It reduces longevity and if you select for longer life that reduces early
fecundity.
That's indicated by these negative signs.
Here it is a complex diagram,
but the important point that it carries is that organisms are bundles of
tradeoffs that are connected to each other and that are not free to evolve
independently of each other and that things that we see at the level of major
life history traits like development time or fecundity are underpinned by
corresponding changes in physiological traits.
That make a lot of sense.
Yeah.
Let's take a look at the phenotypic tradeoff in women.
Here are the number of women for whom fecundity was observed in Framingham,
Massachusetts.
Those are the blue bars,
so you can see that ranges between about 600 and about a thousand these are the
number of children that they had per lifetime that Ceb,
children ever born or lifetime reproductive success.
This is their relative mortality risk here.
Okay,
so the first two children,
these to decrease the risk of death and it then increased linearly with the
third,
fourth,
and the fifth child,
and when we use the pedigrees of the Framingham population to estimate the
genetic component of the variation,
the genetic correlation between children ever born and lifespan was negative.
It was minus 0.88 which is a very,
very strong negative genetic correlation.
In other words,
there was a u shaped relationship for the cost of reproduction for women in
Framingham and the estimated genetic correlation was negative and strong and the
negativity of this correlation is dominated by this portion here of the
phenotypic graph.
We then did a genome wide association study looking for genes that affect the
relationship between children ever born and lifespan and we found two single
nucleotide polymorphisms that were associated with that relationship.
Yeah.
One is near a gene called a Yomis.
It's a master regulator that's also implicated in bladder cancer and in multiple
sclerosis and another is near a gene that's associated with brain development in
vaccine response.
Okay.
In both cases,
the variants that increased lifetime reproductive success,
decreased lifespan,
so they were associated with higher risk later in life.
Yeah.
Others have also found that increase fertility early in life while increasing
risk of chronic disease late in life.
For example,
LDLs in the p 53 pathway.
Here.
Mutations are probably more frequently involved in cancer than any other gene
and here the benefit early in life has to do with implantation success,
so that's an extremely early event and or embryos that implant better into the
endometrium are at increased risk of cancer later in life.
Similarly,
the early onset breast cancer gene brick a is associated with shorter birth
intervals and increased reproductive success in some samples.
The April he fora Leo is a gene that improves cholesterol metabolism but it
increases risk of Alzheimer's so you can see that these are all places where a
gene is conferring enhanced reproductive advantage or enhanced survival
advantage earlier in life,
but is also a gene that confers greater risk for either cancer or a
neurodegenerative disease late in life.
These are cases of antagonistic pleiotropy that support the evolutionary theory
of aging.
Now what about hormones?
Hormones are mediating lots of responses and bodies and they are are arguably
our priori involved in tradeoffs.
Well,
those tradeoffs differ a bit in males and female
and males,
testosterone and other androgens are regulating the allocation of energy between
reproduction and immune functions during infections.
Energy is switched from maintaining skeletal muscle red blood cells and bone
density to increasing the immune response,
and it does so more in males than it doesn't females in uninfected males,
the normal maintenance of secondary sexual characters by androgens diverts
energy away from immune function and increases susceptibility to disease.
For example,
men who receive a few a flu vaccination experience,
a drop in testosterone levels for two weeks compared to a somewhat comparable
control group in brief,
macho can make you sick or it can at least leave you susceptible.
On the other hand,
in females,
Leptin is the hormone mediating tradeoffs between reproduction and survival,
or at least it's one of the important hormones that mediates that relationship,
left and regulates energy intake and expenditure through effects on appetite and
metabolism.
It's secreted by fat cells and it reflects overall fat storage in the body.
It's a signal of body fat content.
It binds to that part of the hypothalamus that's known as the satiety center
where it signals that the body has eaten enough.
It inhibits neurons that stimulate eating and it stimulates neurons that inhibit
eating.
Yeah.
When women come under nutritional stress,
some reproductive traits respond sensitively and some do not,
and these reactions are mediated by Leptin.
Ovarian function,
duration of gestation and final birth weight are sensitive to energy balance,
but the rate at which energy is supplied to the embryo by the mother is much
less sensitive.
Yeah,
pregnant and nursing mothers are strongly stressed by poor nutrition,
which causes the early birth of underweight infants and increases inter birth
intervals of their mothers.
However,
milk production is relatively insensitive to stress and this is why even in
starving populations you will see mothers whose bodies are shrinking,
continuing to lactate and continuing to circle their infants.
There is an interesting trade off at the population level and we're going to use
this concept later on,
which is why I'm introducing it in this introductory lecture on tradeoffs
deviations from normal,
which is something you might think of as being the adaptive center of a
distribution are often unavoidable and they have costs.
Any complex process that's composed of components.
Each of which can vary will be expressed as a range of phenotypes that has a
central peak and it has rare extremes,
so it has,
it's a distribution that has a frequent center and rare tails.
If the center is selected,
then this is the condition to which individuals in the population are adapted.
They are not adapted to the extremes.
However,
the extremes are unavoidable.
This is somewhat similar to the concept of recombination will load in population
genetics,
but in fact it's produced both by genetics and by development.
It's produced by anything that causes variation in the components of conflicts,
traits.
Individuals here are functioning well.
They are one portion of the population.
Individuals in the tails are functioning poorly.
They are another rarer portion of the population and so this is really a
population level tradeoff.
A critical question is whether tradeoffs actually evolve more slowly than do
other traits.
Sometimes,
in fact,
they evolved nearly as fast,
so in bacteria,
antibiotic resistance is thought to be costly.
It's thought to be bound up in a trade off.
In other words,
it's good when the antibiotic is there,
but it slows the bacteria down when the antibiotic is not there.
However,
if you ask,
how rapidly do the cost of antibiotic resistance disappear when bacteria are
selected in the presence of antibiotics,
the answer is,
well,
pretty fast.
This is called compensatory evolution and it can eliminate the cost of
antibiotic resistance in bacteria within about six months of selection.
Now,
what's the importance of that?
Yeah,
well,
as soon as genes for resistance,
no longer have a fitness cost.
In the absence of the antibiotics.
When you pull out the antibiotic,
you're the bacteria.
They've evolved resistance,
but in no longer cost them anything.
The resistance sheets have become neutral,
and what that means is that they're much,
much slower to disappear.
They persist in the population for a long time.
Now,
this rapid evolution of a tradeoff makes the tradeoff disappear fairly quickly.
In this case,
it was a fairly simple trait and it was possible for evolution to adjust it.
Evolution will act to reduce costs where ever they are consistently expressed
and encountered and to Redo and where reduction is possible.
Now,
in many cases,
tradeoffs persist because reduction is not possible.
And in other cases,
they persist because the conditions under which the costs are expressed or also
infrequent.
Okay?
So to summarize,
tradeoffs are everywhere.
They're the default condition.
All traits are bound up,
usually in some kind of trade off.
For traits in the patient that are involved in trade offs,
a change that improves one condition could worse than another.
For example,
the negative side effects of many drugs.
So you have improved symptoms for the thing that drug is targeting,
but you have negative side effects.
The tradeoff between testosterone and disease resistance in males,
and importantly,
the tradeoff between reproduction and survival that shapes the evolution of
aging.